una notte ho sentito dei passi vicino al
mio letto e io in door in the che vi ho
detto te ne vai che questa persona se
n'è andata toccandomi sfiorandomi le
lenzuola ecco queste mi fanno cagare
addosso ad esempio
ciao ragazzi benvenuti a una puntata di
vita buttata il tema della puntata di
oggi è esperienze paranormali il ritorno
cosa accendere la luce che abbiamo fatto
questa caricata quindi ho finalmente
dobbiamo fare uno dei temi che a me
hanno divertito più in assoluto nella
vita esperienze paranormali
ecco perché per poter trattare questo
tipo di argomento non ho potuto non
invitare all'interno degli studios di
casa mia
l'unica persona con la quale mi sento a
mio agio nel parlare di queste
esperienze ossia l'unico e inimitabile
jam pazzo salve a tutti io non sono
pazzo
gianmarco mio cugino ed ha buttata non è
solo divertimento scoregge con le
ascelle nerd perché tutti quanti hanno
sempre qualcosa legato alle feci da
condividere ma è anche il mistero
intrigo passione per chi non lo sapesse
gli audio che arrivano vengono
selezionati dal più sintetici degli
audio io perdo la vita da fare questo
lavoro normale il fatto che gianmarco
sappiate ma tocca il culo né forse in
realtà inesistenti vetri di natiche ma
perché io ho comunque un gusto lungo e
delle gambe così ma come mai stai seduto
codice si chiama semplicemente avere la
schiena dritta non ho impiegato a novara
come la tua ora cominciamo sacco e cia
ospite che vivono una casa che avete è
infestata porte che si privano da sole a
bottiglie d'acqua che cadevano per le
scale palline da tennis che vedevamo
cadere per le scale e non c'era normale
episodio in particolare è stato quando
io non è mica abbiamo deciso di fare una
purificazione a casa mia a un certo
punto il suo telefono si è sbloccato da
solo e ha iniziato a digitare sulla
tastiera dei numeri il tasto cancelletto
a ripetizione per ogni domanda che noi
facevamo quindi è stato un po come fare
un discorso a un'entità para così si
presenta
carter ha risentito palline da tennis
che non esistevano ma aprite di un
negozio di palline da tennis
per quanto riguarda esperienze
paranormali ne ho solamente una che
ritengo diciamo degno di nota era in
camera mia stavo controllando le ultime
cose al telefono e poi deciso di andare
a dormire era impossibile che mi fossi
addormentata perché avevo appena finito
di guardare il telefono di un certo
punto inizia a sentire dei passi fuori
dalla porta di camera mia mi sono
avvicinato rapporto love dopo l'ho
aperta di scatto orlando chi c'è e nel
momento in cui ho aperto la porta i
passi sono spariti ovviamente non c'era
nessuno i giorni alla pelle d'oca perché
i passi il grande classico del
paranormale grande classico del
paranormale terrorizzante io sto
provando ad applicare una forma di
razionalità all'esperienza opera normali
io sono uno crede a determinati fenomeni
ma evito di credere a tutto cio è quindi
era un tarlo che siete totale aereo si è
infatti davvero io mi sarei soffocato il
bambino
in realtà le esperienze paranormali non
riguarda prettamente né ma la mia mamma
e riguarda anche il mio nonno che era
venuto a mancare da non troppo tempo e
che come si fa di solito aveva lasciato
dei segnali a suo figlio tra cui un
anello che non si sa come mio padre a un
certo punto perde un giorno mia madre
era spolverare la libreria a un certo
punto sento una folata gelida alle
spalle si volta e vede mio nonno che
esso ridandole alza le mani
lei sente proprio le sue mani sollevarsi
le indica un libro mia madre alza il
libro è sotto quel libro c'era questo
famigerato nell ormai perduto mi passi
quello leggo freddo
guarda che bello c'è maggiore di tipo
nonno nostro se facesse una cosa così
però te fabian colpo era molto grottesco
in alcuni suoi aspetti non ho seguita
merini
ma se vuole farmi cacare sotto a dare
lustro dove vogliamo dire al pubblico
cosa succedeva si entrava in quel
camerino c'era un cadavere creato da mio
nonno che chiamava leopoldo con bulone
giungere alla sua biografia si sia il
pazzo cioè lui voleva creare come il
dottor frankestein la sua creatura
sì mi casca ray sono e sotto aprivi quel
camerino aveva messo tipo un
marchingegno cui lui faceva tipo così
per venirti addosso ma è pazzo palese
figli e la tortura si era fatto trovare
sul gra per ac girava in macchina fino
gradualmente pazzo
noi siamo pazzi a se questo gene sua ma
infatti speriamo non mi appaia mai e
abita in campagna quindi se 90 narrato
tetto di niente trattamento profeta ma
di stare in casa da sola è distinto i
rumori battuti da parte della casa passa
in inverno con le finestre chiuse quindi
assicurata che non ci fosse uno spiffero
prima di darmi addosso a tavola nella
mia camera e qualcuno mi bussa alla
porta convinta fosse mia matrigna
agrital e mamma non rispondeva nessuno
alla fine apre rapporto mi rendo conto
che mia madre e la mia uscita da un ora
a comprare il pane che restano in casa
dal tarlo di prima in realtà lo faccia
dei piedi delle mani pesantissime
ragazzi a volte non riesco a commentare
perché mikako troppo sotto queste in
sicila pure da noi capitano un po sì
abbiamo parlato anche la scorsa puntata
infatti se volete recuperarla
vi lasciamo posto brano state cose se sì
el'altra cucinavo coltrane san fratello
sentiamo bussare alla porta vada bene e
non c'era nessuno torniamo a cucinare
commenti le feci sbagliati e un carillon
e calo all'ingresso iniziò a suonare per
averla scettico come la morte mi dice
che si stava allentata la molla e quindi
aveva suonato magicamente da solchi
esportiamo in canna per giocare alla
pelle e le maschere inventato
dell'interruttore dell'ingresso nel
corridoio e nel bagno mi fino a natale
accadono
una dopo l'altra in ordine man mano che
si avvicinava tipo qualcuno verso la
meta mera avevo la porta per della
camera ci voltiamo di scatto e vedendo
qualcosa mentre eravamo girati armadi
della mia camera un'auto stava
tranquillamente da solo molto lentamente
sgretolando comunque il moro perché il
mio fratello molto scettico de chile dal
fratello maggiore coraggioso di prendere
e andare al parco a giocare a pallone
per evitare di pensare a questa non
graziosissimo nonno ma va bene così
progettare di un fiume nel parco per
proteggere il fratello minore ma voi che
siete dei mocciosi non potete capire
cosa farebbe un fratello maggiore che
cosa farei
prendi noi praticamente stavo dormendo
mi sveglio sintonizzabile bloccarmi che
aveva in camera poco dopo mi rendo conto
che non c'è e del mio orecchio sento una
persona che sospira
vabbè mi spavento poi cerco già mi
riaddormento il giorno dopo mentre sto
dormendo
mi sveglio di colpo perché mi cade una
mano addosso è spaventatissimo accendo
la luce era la mia mano però io non idea
di come si sia mosse come sia caduta su
di me ci tenevo a dirti che comunque
essere l'unica persona che seguo su
youtube cui sono iscritta e il guardo
solo te va bene una settimana sia
riuscita a vedere tutti i tuoi video
perché è una vita molto sociale come
l'uomo mi fai morire dalle risate votare
battuto i tuoi fratelli bambina chiunque
vi fate morire fatti non è detto
gianmarco distrutto mio cugino si gira
verso il divano e mi dice ma chi è
quella signora seduta nel divano guardo
quella vecchietta seduta sull'iva non
riconosco in lei mia nonna che è morta
quando io ero molto piccola e che mio
cugino non aveva mai conosciuto essendo
tanti anni più piccolo di me questa
ricetta al die o chi ci guarda ci
sorride io e lui rimane moscow molti ci
guardiamo in faccia quindi disfiamo lo
sguardo dalla vecchia e li scompare
a queste solo tanto assurde no non lo so
io non lo so perché non mi è mai
capitato non lo so gianmarco non lo so
c'è un guscio ospite eravamo una casa in
montagna con gli amici c'era una cantina
piena di legna per il camino
eravamo tutti a cenare e niente sentiamo
appunto rumore di legna che cade un
casino assurdo scendiamo in cantina e la
legna è completamente a posto siamo
guardati tutti straniti ci affacciamo
alla finestra e c'erano sulla neve i
segni delle gomme di un'auto ma nessuna
auto pensa che poi per lo spirito che ha
buttato tutta la lega la rimessa a posto
e ai fedato in una macchina parlava
arabo e qui forte comunque fra casino ma
rimette a posto presto prima che meglio
la faccio a favore di una mimica di
tenere il cane dorme con me finché alle
3 di notte ad abbaiare verso la porta di
camera mia l'ho lasciato un po aperta
esce di camera rientra e si butta sul
mio letto con la coda in mezzo alle
gambe e ringhia fortissimo contro la
porta io non sapevo che fare ero
pietrificata mi precipito a chiudere la
porta e le finisce tutto penso di essere
stato svegliato ipo fino alle sei della
mattina ho più volte successo e gould mi
facesse la stessa cosa si è messo ad
abbaiare come un dannato contro un muro
dobbiamo anche considerare che quel cane
non gode di una intelligenza di quelle
elevate s per santo quel caso gli
animali sono come posseggono gli istinti
delle percezioni magari che a me possono
sfuggire anche se dicono che in realtà
ognuno dovrebbe avere in casa un cane un
gatto perché i cani proteggono il mondo
materiale e gatti invece il mondo
spirituale
si divorano a vicenda ragazzi volevo
raccontarvi una piccola esperienza e che
è capitata a me e il mio compagno in
macchina qualche anno fa lo so
attraversando l'autostrada torino savona
nebbia fittissima piena notte davanti a
noi vediamo attraversarci una ragazza
capelli lunghissimi neri e una camicia
da notte per il mio compagno inchioda e
diciamo hai visto anche tu quello che ho
visto io tornati a casa abbiamo cercato
online informazioni su quel tratto di
autostrada c'era un blog che parlava di
persone che avevano già fatto queste
esperienze da morale che noi ce la siamo
fatta sotto
io nel tempo dietro ci fu un incidente
dove morì una ragazza in quelle
condizioni
le fattezze ecco qual è il tratto
stradale che non ci andrò mai al mutande
marroni quest'area positano intendeva
nomi che ho preso tre centimetri in
altezza sulla serie a mai più fare
questo tema mai più io mi aspettavo ciao
e mi è arrivato
eccole era questo quello di prima ciao
ciao è un attacco la mia famiglia ad una
messa un po particolari a un certo punto
si va a prendere l'ostia punto una
signora dietro di me e che comincia a
ritorcersi cade per terra si mette
all'indietro con le braccia e le camere
non so se avete presente uno ragnoli
indietro non sapremo esattamente con
descrivere comincia ad urlare ricade per
terra si ripiega comica un liquido verde
o di quanti hanno cominciato a pregare
io piangevo madonna che paura che se poi
quel esorcista io non voglio mai più
fare questo tema non voglio fare mai più
ma è un po come il sublime di kant una
votava la riesch e ma allo stesso tempo
dirà se è vero è un po come su prima di
casa
è vero filosofo vomito spirito 42 anni
ma quando ero piccolo nonostante avessi
un fratello una sorella ero
prevalentemente un bambino solo e
solitario anche perché comunque avevo il
mio amichetto immaginario che si
chiamava poi sentimenti allo specchio in
bagno al buio con gli occhi chiusi
perché aprendoli dopo qualche secondo
riuscivo a vedere i lineamenti del suo
viso nello specchio ma dietro di me non
so se paranormale non so se ti può
parlare di angelo custode io so solo che
tutte le volte che ho bisogno di un non
si io chiedo boris ma che siamo pazzi
terrorizza il fatto che tu dici vede
un'ombra scura e dietro di sé sa e non
una fonte di luce buon adelina un uomo
grande e grosso errori dato secondo la
vita insieme a boris abbiamo un'immagine
un'immagine aspetta riassumo quindi lui
si fa una foto da mente questo capannone
abbandonato e lei dopo nota che da una
delle cose ci sono due o due tocchi
lei intende questi quando avevo 14 anni
è il mio miglior amico e siamo andati su
una casa abbandonata nella mia città e
c'era uno stanza tipo coperta tutta con
telo bianco non lo so e mi avevano tocca
e la stanza dietro di noi all'improvviso
alla volta si chiude abbiamo provato in
tutti i modi hp perché se fosse chiusa
abbiamo provato a spingere la porta però
era tipo bloccata da un mattone quindi
in teoria la porta non si poteva chiude
6 anni dopo lo zio adesso amico mio ci
fa vedere la foto di un fantasma che gli
ha fatto la foto a una modella e se vede
un fantasma vicino a sta tipa
praticamente abbiamo scoperto che lui ha
fatto la foto in quella stanza dove era
chiusa la porta per un altro avversario
siamo sempre su quella casa o altri
amici all'improvviso un amico mio fare
che avete sentito il suo cane che abbaia
ma nomadi rivedremo il video avevamo
fatto un video è una certa 60 e cane che
abbaia e l'amico mio per favore che
avete sentito il cane che abbaia rimasti
tutti comunque ci sono i bought the
stars vedere no un'altra bellissima
stavo a casa da sola a me stava
preparata da casa dell'amica sa bene
stava fa il trucco me guarda allo
specchio e sento la voglia che mi fa
ammazza quanto si brutta io senza
pensarci gli ho risposto di paesi bello
2 che non teneva a dopo realizzato che
stavo a casa da sola e ho fatto un
furgone vado a casa dell'amica una certa
vedo qualcuno sulla poltrona che guarda
la tv e faceva bene sarà la madre è una
certa vedo la mega mia con la madre su
un'altra stanza a parlare di kakà oggi a
giornata dei fantasmi cabeccia zii e
modo aridaje allo sma spa di via dopo
come questa porta si è chiusa viola mi
come ci siamo trovati la stesse dalle
tipografie sullo stesso identico punto
sul braccio piaceva la sua tecnica
narrativa che altro un cafone o spirito
ragazza permetto infatti racconta di
quella volta che sono andata in vacanza
con la mia famiglia mio fratello
piccolino si era portato al pupazzo dvd
i tuoi story solo che un certo punto la
vacanza ci rendiamo conto di avere solo
il cappello
io ti giri a me lo ricordo che se l'era
portato c'era maresi di averlo perso una
volta tornati a casa troviamo il pupazzo
una cesta di giochi nella nostra stanza
né io né i miei genitori ci riusciamo a
spiegare questo avvenimento non ci sono
spiegazioni ce n'è solo una hai un amico
in te a me questo è un l'inter mi co in
manette speranza sì un grande amico è
veramente allora vado a credere che il
giocattolo sa di veramente è l'unico
caso che non mi mette paura di oggetti
animati e vedere un woody che cammina un
buio un bacione di gara quelli di thomas
potato mister potato zurg a tutti i
gironi sono camminare tutti il resto i
termini
dovrà prendere l'autobus che mi
riportasse il paese quando mi si
affianca un bambino facendomi delle
domande dicendo mesi mi piace andare a
scuola cosa facevo lì quando stavo per
rispondere qui in giro questo bambino
non c'era più ora abbiamo un doppio
chiamali capelli a caschetto stati hanno
detto che la descrizione e io avevo dato
era uguale a quella di un bambino morto
lì con un incidente stradale simile alla
dinamica della vostra è identica
macaulay culkin pagemaster terrorizzante
terrorizzante terrorizzante
terrorizzante terrorizzanti bambini
terrorizzante perché i bambini sono
terrorizza nel maggio di bambino che fa
chi è quel signore lì e indica verso il
vuoto
io prendo il bambino quadra come che
sport che si aprono silvio non da solo e
oggetti che si muovono da solo a
progetti che si muovono da solo
[Risate]
auguri elmo ciao gianmarco si verso che
sarà gian marco perché sono un medico ma
classe se non c'è già marco tagliate
questa parte se non faccio brutta tifoso
una sera avevamo ospiti a cena e la
televisione si è accesa all'improvviso
da sola il pomeriggio successivo stavo
riposando in camera pero chi in casa da
solo che sento un ronzio provenire dalla
cucina vado giù in cucina e trovo la
cappa accesa il tasto era su off faceva
avanti e indietro con il tasto su one
off e non si spegneva io panico totale
stacco la spina e finalmente la cappa si
è spenta la notte alle 3 seri accesa la
tv da sola essendo un botto in cucina
vado e trovo il frigorifero
completamente spalancato scena da film
horror
ragazzi io ho per un periodo avevo un
tipo d'allarme in casa e quello lì con
le telecamere le ho tolte alla fine ho
dovuto cambiare ormai solo sensori
sembrava vedere l'inquadratura di un
film horror militello
poco poco pi di un cuscino che minuto
impazzì sia poi tu sei pure intrappolato
a quel piano e non ai modi per uscire
sì sì quattro piani di voto è tratto da
fuga migliore quella questa storia nasce
l'ultimo giorno della gita di quinta
liceo andiamo a questo monumento che si
trova su una collina e ci facciamo un
sensi tutti insieme uno dei professori
la pubblica su facebook e solo a questo
punto ci accorgiamo e nella foto c'è
qualcuno in più ma che è marzo atac è
uguale allora hanno scattato diverse
foto ma solamente in questa ci sta
questa figura gli eroi de mars attack
mi trovavo a casa di il mio migliore
amico dell'epoca e stavamo io lui e suo
fratello più piccolo
guardando tipo una puntata di spongebob
certo punto vedo questa ombra una specie
di cosa di fumo che passa nel cortile
loro due rimangono abbastanza
impossibile per punto mi riguarda gamma
vogliamo far finta di niente o l'avete
visto pure voi come famosissima beh ma è
normale che succedono cose mi hanno
raccontato che di notte si spostavano
sedie niente alzano mac è andata a casa
sua che pure vedo nubi di fumo gli
importatori con lanciano coerenza
magari che sta al ristorante la dietro
c'hanno la cappa di ferrero ragazzi
siamo arrivati alla fine di questo video
che dire ragazzi come sempre vi invito a
metterci un po alle censure registriamo
scrivi a questo canale attivare la
campanellina delle notifiche che è
importantissima sia per buona fortuna e
sia perché vi permetterà di non perdere
i contenuti di questo canale qualora
facesse piacere
fateci sapere quali sono state le vostre
esperienze paranormali non le leggerò o
non di lotta quindi leggere solo la
mattina appena sveglio che altro dire ci
vediamo questa domenica con una puntata
di cucina buttata alle 12 ciao ciao